les multinationales risque de poursuivre
les états pour leurs pertes liées au
coût de 19 un collectif de 632 ong du
monde entier s'en alarme en juin dernier
elle avait dans une lettre tenter de
prévenir les autorités sur cette menace
qui se précise un peu partout dans le
monde on l'a appris à la mi-août dans la
presse britannique de grands cabinets
d'avocats conseils ouvertement leur
client d'engager des procédures contre
leur état ainsi au royaume uni 3
compagnie aérienne ryanair british
airways et easyjet ont déjà organisé
engagé des poursuites contre les mesures
imposant une quatorzaine aux voyageurs
venant de l'étranger va en parler
justement on va retrouver vincent berger
il est avocat spécialiste du droit
international ancien jury consulte à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
est ce que en france le gouvernement
doit craindre aussi à des poursuites
comme c'est déjà le cas autrement alors
il peut le craindre des poursuites mais
à mon avis le risque est tout de même
extrêmement limité il peut plus
exactement faire l'objet d'une demande
de demande en réparation devant les
juridictions administratives françaises
mais les chances de succès de ces
actions me paraissent à première vue
extrêmement limité il faudrait arriver à
prouver que les mesures prises par les
autorités françaises étaient
manifestement excessive ou
disproportionnées ou que leur
application n'était pas été un peu
discriminatoire entre catégories de
l'entreprise par exemple
donc tout cela me paraît extrêmement
douteux ce qui me frappe aussi c'est
qu'on a parlé aussi de cette déclaration
des ong
là encore leurs cracks me paraissent
très très peu fondée dès lors que en
matière de protection des
investissements internationaux lien plus
de 2600 traités bilatéraux
d'investissement
il faudrait arriver à approuver s'il
était investi tle des investisseurs
était lésée par certains états dans le
monde
arrivé à prouver que
l'état de nécessité ou l'état d'urgence
qui est à supposer qu'il soit prévu dans
ces traités bilatéraux n'existait pas ce
qui paraîtrait sans doute assez
difficile à prouver
donc moi je ne suis pas trop inquiet
j'estime que c'est ces craintes des ong
dont vous vous venez de parler me
paraissent à première vue très
accessible on a vu qu au royaume uni
sont des deux grandes entreprises qui
sont concernés des compagnies aériennes
on sait qu'en france par exemple des
secteurs qui grognent en face aux
restrictions c'est le cas notamment par
exemple des boîtes de nuit en france
quelles sont les entreprises qui
seraient susceptibles de porter plainte
contre l'état français alors tous eu
tout ce qui s'est effectivement s'estime
gravement lésés qui voient leur
existence même remise en cause et vous
allez venez de parler des discothèques
je crois que c'est un très très bon
exemple et là encore il sera mon avis
extrêmement difficile pour ces
entreprises de montrer que les mesures
prises par les autorités était présenté
un caractère excessif ou
disproportionnées ou que leur durée
d'application était beaucoup trop longue
donc tout ça peut naturellement en
prêter à des actions en justice
je viens de dire devant les juridictions
administratives
mais je pense que il faudrait qu'elles
réfléchissent à deux fois avant de
lancer dans une telle aventure
même si certains comme tenté de l'est et
pousse les concept direction le sens le
cas britannique on a vu dans les
colonnes du guardian que les cabinets
d'avocats incitent leurs clients
investisseurs internationaux à attaquer
les états qui auraient donc pris des
mesures de restriction qui leur
apportera donc préjudice comment
juridiquement peuvent prendre en général
donc je viens d'expliquer il y à des
traités bilatéraux d'investissement qui
protège les investissements étrangers
dans un état donné il y en a plus de
2600 aujourd'hui donc c'est un
extraordinaire maillage qui couvre
quasiment la planète entière
il ya très peu d'états au monde qui ne
sont pas liés plus ou moins par des
traités bilatéraux d'investissement et
donc il s'agira dans chacun de voir
quelles sont les possibilités offertes
aux investisseurs pour mettre en cause
devant une juridiction d'arbitrage
puisque c'est que ces traités bilatéraux
prévoit une justice privée c'est-à-dire
un arbitrage international
confiée à des arbitres et donc il faudra
voir pour chaque que traité bilatéral
quelles sont les possibilités offertes à
cette entreprise et donc ce sera je un
vraiment un
une étude au cas par cas on ne pourra
absolument pas généraliser et donc mais
je ne doute pas de l'ingéniosité de mes
confrères britanniques pour essayer de
trouver des failles mais comme je viens
je les dis tout à fait au début je suis
a priori assez sceptique quant aux
chances de succès de ce genre de
procédure devant un tribunal arbitral
du côté des ong ont craint le recours à
un dispositif déjà très controversé le
rdi un mécanisme de règlement entre
différents des différends entre
investisseurs et et à celle de quoi
s'agit-il là alors c'est un mécanisme
extrêmement bien rodée qui fonctionne
notamment dans le cadre de de la banque
mondiale à washington et qui permet aux
entreprises et aux états de donc de
soumettre leur différend hors matière
d'investissements à une juridiction
arbitrale qui est supposé être
indépendante et impartiale
ce système a souvent été critiqué par
des ong mais en même temps il présente
de très grands avantages pour la vie des
entreprises
même si on ne peut pas exclure que
puisse y avoir c'est une un des défis
palliant 11 de ce type de justice mais
c'est une justice qui présente beaucoup
davantage de rapidité et aussi de
confidentialité ce qui est très
important pour le secret des affaires
merci à vous vincent berger rappelle que
vous êtes avocat spécialiste du droit
international ancien jury consulte de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
merci m